[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
question d'actualité sur LCP c'est la
dernière séance de questions au
gouvernement ce mardi à l'Assemblée les
députés boucles la session
extraordinaire après une année bien
agitée dernière séance aussi pour
quelques ministres puisqu’un remaniement
est attendu dans les prochains jours en
revanche chez les abais de borne devrait
arriver confortés dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale cet après-midi
puisqu'elle a été maintenue à Matignon
annonce de l'Élysée hier soir alors on
va revenir sur cette actualité et toute
l'actualité parlementaire avec Stéphanie
Despierres et Elsa mon Agava qui se
trouve salle des quatre colonnes vous
retrouverez comme d'habitude Marco
pommier dans les tribunes de l'hémicycle
pour le menu des questions au
gouvernement et puis vous verrez en
direct sur LCP l'arrivée de la première
ministre et des membres du gouvernement
ce sera cours d'honneur à partir de
14h45 à 14h50 ensuite vous verrez aussi
l'arrivée de la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui viendra donc
assister à cette séance de questions à
suivre en direct et en intégralité sur
LCP à 15h alors on va retrouver Elsa mon
Agava qui se trouve salle des quatre
colonnes Elsa entre le remaniement et
les conclusions de la commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur les
hubert-files il faut s'attendre à une
après-midi un peu agité cet après-midi
oui Brigitte tout à fait on vous le
savez l'assemblée devrait siéger jusqu'à
dimanche grand maximum mais il y a
toujours de l'actualité les conclusions
sur la commission d'enquête hubert-féles
j'ai cru entendre dire que le président
est la rapporteur sur votre plateau
n'était pas tout à fait d'accord il y a
éventuellement le remaniement qui et
quand et puis deux textes qui vont
occuper les députés celui sur
l'industrie verte et puis jeudi en
séance celui sur le projet de loi
d'urgence sur la reconstruction vous le
savez après les émeutes qu'on connu le
pays allez on prend tout de suite la
direction de l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale où se trouve Marco pommier
Marco est-ce qu'il y a un thème qui se
dégage de cette dernière séance de
questions cet après-midi
écoutez brigitte c'est un double thème
qui s'impose cet après-midi avec d'abord
plusieurs questions autour de la santé
sur la fermeture des services d'urgence
notamment
pardon pardonnez-moi des urgences sous
haute tension cet été en raison du
manque de soignants notamment on parlera
aussi de la santé mentale des jeunes et
de la situation des EHPAD en période
estivale autre sujet le coût de
l'énergie les tarifs de l'électricité
vont grimper de 10% au premier août
prochain pour un ménage en moyenne ça
représenterait 150 euros de plus par an
soit 13 euros par mois ce n'est qu'une
étape dans la fin progressive du
bouclier tarifaire il s'arrêtera à la
fin de l'année 2024 merci Marco et on
vous retrouvera un petit peu plus tard
dans cette émission pour le con le menu
complet des de ces questions au
Gouvernement voici un présent mes
invités sur ce plateau pour cette
première partie de questions d'actu
Benjamin adap bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes député renaissance de
Paris et Daniel Simonet bonjour bonjour
bienvenue à vous vous êtes député la
France insoumise de Paris également
alors je vous le disais tout à l'heure
Elisabeth borne reviendra en force cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale elles a mon
ningava il est vrai qu'hier l'Elysée a
confirmé le maintien à Matignon de la
première ministre au terme des 100 jours
d'apaisement voulu par le Président de
la République après la réforme des
retraites oui les oppositions ironisées
sur ce maintien Mathilde la chef des
insoumis a dit bien personne ne veut
monter sur un bateau qui coule côté
majorité on prend acte de cette décision
avec plus ou moins d'enthousiasme
effectivement un changement de Premier
ministre ne changera de toute façon pas
l'état du pays nous confiait un député
de la majorité un changement aurait pu
être vécu comme une provocation soit
pour la droite soit pour la gauche nous
disait un autre et on s'accorde pour
dire que de toute façon les Français ont
la tête en vacances
alors Elsa un remaniement est également
attendu dans les prochains jours oui on
parle d'ajustement alors ce qu'on a
essayé de savoir ce matin aux quatre
colonnes c'est ce qu'on entendait par un
ajustement est-ce que c'est un petit
remaniement technique ou un grand
remaniement politique et là pour être
honnête bien les députés de la majorité
ont des avis différents alors ils
prennent tous beaucoup de prudence dont
3 jours j'aurais peut-être torture tout
je ne sais pas ce qui va se décider
prévient-il avant de continuer il y a
deux hypothèses soit de gros ministères
pourraient être concernés par le
remaniement on peut penser à la santé
avec François Brune ou à l'éducation
avec papendaye soit on peut penser à un
remaniement beaucoup plus technique avec
un des changements de ministre à minima
en tout cas ce que les députés de la
majorité appellent de leurs vœux c'est
un gouvernement pardon plus resserré
plus politique et s'il n'y a pas de
grand changement le gouvernement
d'Elisabeth borne restera en CDD nous
promet un député rien n'est figé les
choses pourraient bouger un peu plus
fortement d'ici l'automne vous le voyez
même si on parle du remaniement
maintenant on pourra toujours en parler
à la rentrée
merci Elsa mandingava Benjamin Haddad on
a appris donc hier que la première
ministre était maintenue à Matignon par
l'entourage de l'Elysée alors
qu'Emmanuel Macron est à Bruxelles
est-ce qu'il faut y voir finalement un
maintien mais sans sans grand
enthousiasme de la première ministre
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour le
pays c'est une première ministre qui a
été courageux qui a porté des réformes
difficiles à son terme on pense
notamment à la réforme des retraites
elle avait 100 jours pour apaiser pour
relancer aussi un nouveau programme de
réforme bon c'est toutes les questions
d'industrialisation de plein emploi de
transition environnementale beaucoup de
chantiers qui ont été lancés un dialogue
qui a été repris aussi avec les
partenaires sociaux nous notre groupe
est très heureux de continuer à
travailler avec Isabelle borne et
continuer à la soutenir parce qu'il
reste énormément de choses à faire pour
continuer à faire baisser le chômage de
notre pays pour continuer à investir
dans la transition de continuer aussi à
réarmer le régalien la sécurité l'armée
comme on l'a fait depuis le début de ce
quinquennat pendant ces 100 jours le
président de la République lui avait
confié une mission celle d'élargir la
majorité est-ce qu'elle a échoué non
mais vous savez depuis le début on
travaille avec les oppositions
responsables constructives textes par
textes dans cette situation inédite de
majorité relative les deux tiers des PPL
du groupe Renaissance ont été adoptés à
l'unanimité on a su trouver il faut
continuer d'ailleurs à faire ce travail
de compromis de négociation qui je pense
est une chance pour la démocratie dans
notre pays et en tout cas on a vu des
textes adoptés parfois des sujets
majeurs pensons à la loi de
programmation militaire qui permet de
rehausser nos ambitions sur les
questions de défense après des décennies
de sous-investissement à ce débat
fondamental aussi sur l'industrie verte
en ce moment qui a lieu dans l'hémicycle
alors Daniel Simonet Elizabeth borne et
confirmé est-ce que vous y voyez vous un
nouveau sursis pour la première ministre
écoutez en fait il y a que Emmanuel
Macron et les siens à être satisfait du
bilan de Madame borne parce que
franchement c'est une catastrophe c'est
l'inaction climatique au niveau social
c'est la violence de cette
contre-réforme des retraites au niveau
démocratique c'est quand même la plus
grande dégaineuse du 49-3 et d'ailleurs
le problème c'est pas tant le problème
de quelle personne on met au poste de
première ministre mais quelle politique
vous n'avez pas demandé son départ
d'ailleurs mais vous savez remplacer
Isabelle borne par quelqu'un d'autre de
toute façon Monsieur Emmanuel Macron
abuse des de la Constitution de la
Cinquième République pour concentrer le
maximum de pouvoir et on voit bien que
de toute façon il a finalement il joue
le rôle de président de la République de
Premier ministre il enose tous les
portefeuilles vraiment et il n'y aura
pas de changement de de cap de cette
politique or c'est cette politique
ultralibérale anti écologique antisocial
et antidémocratique parce que ça a été
une année vraiment de mépris
démocratique à outrance c'est de tout
cela dont on voudrait tourner la page
alors vous entendez Daniel Simonet c'est
vrai qu'on nous avait promis son jour
d'apaisement entre temps il y a eu la
mort de Naël il y a eu ses émeutes
urbaines qui ont un peu plus
agité le pays
finalement est-ce que tout cela ne
montre pas l'échec de ces 100 jours non
la mort de Naël les émeutes je crois
qu'ils ont touché tout notre pays les
premières victimes sont d'ailleurs tous
les gens dont les voitures les
transports les écoles les mairies ont
été brûlés c'est élus locaux qui ont été
agressés on assure rétablir le calme
avec le déploiement de 45000 policiers
et gendarmes sur le terrain et je crois
que ça vous fera évidemment des débats
sur la restauration de l'autorité dans
notre pays l'autorité à l'école
l'autorité de la police aussi dans ces
quartiers avoir une politique de
l'éducation et du logement qui sont
ambitieux aussi pour ces quartiers ça a
été déjà le cas depuis quelques années
on peut penser au dédoublement des des
classes dans les zones prioritaires qui
vraiment un chantier générationnel qui
va avoir un impact pour énormément
d'enfants qui sont aujourd'hui à l'école
à la réduction du chômage des jeunes un
niveau historique le plus faible depuis
40 ans il faut continuer vous la voyez
vous cette forme d'apaisement Daniel
Simonet non pas du tout et ce qui est
tragique c'est qu'après la de Noël il
n'y a pas eu un seul mot un seul message
du gouvernement pour essayer de répondre
à ce qui a provoqué la colère dans les
quartiers populaires on est face à un
véritable problème des violences
policières et il faut comprendre comment
éviter les autres morts de Naël on sait
pertinemment que la loi 2017 cette sur
la légitime défense neuve qui finalement
autorise à tirer sur des voitures
lorsqu'elles ont un refus d'obtempérer a
provoqué 13 morts donc c'est 13 mars
qu'on aurait pu éviter il faut savoir
qu'en Allemagne en disant il n'y en a eu
un seul et j'aurais vraiment aimé qu'il
y ait des mots d'apaisement des mots de
compréhension en fait du gouvernement
pour vraiment engager la paix et non pas
la répression vous savez dans les
quartiers populaires on sait que il y a
à la fois énormément de discrimination
et il y a un accès aux services publics
extrêmement détérioré par rapport à
d'autres quartiers de la République ça
c'est pas acceptable et là s'il n'y a
aucune prise en compte de cela vous
savez la République pour pouvoir y
construire la paix il faut souder les
citoyens et les citoyennes en étant en
capacité de prendre en compte ce que le
message de la République veut dire et
donc la lutte contre le racisme dans
notre société et la lutte contre le
racisme systémique dans la police est
nécessaire et je regrette que ce
gouvernement n'est pas eu un mot à ce
sujet
on va pas refaire le débat mais on nous
promet des ajustements maintenant de ce
gouvernement qui faut-il changer dans
cette équipe gouvernementale sur ce qui
vient d'être dit parce que on ne peut
pas parler de violence policière on ne
peut pas laisser insulter de cette façon
les policiers les gendarmes qui au péril
de leur vie courageusement protège les
Français il y a eu 1000 policiers et
gendarmes qui ont été blessés dans ces
émeutes quand il y a des réactions
disproportionnées quand il y a des morts
vous avez entendu le président de la
République vous avez entendu le ministre
intérieur Gérald Darmanin qui ont été
d'une clarté d'une fermeté absolue pour
dire que la professionnel était
inacceptable et d'ailleurs la justice
fait son travail le policier a été mis
en examen mais moi je refuse que l'on
éclabousse de cette façon l'ensemble
d'une profession qui travaille dans des
conditions qui sont difficiles qui
travaillent dans des conditions ils sont
difficiles
à dire que la police tue qui continue
régulièrement à insulter les policiers
légendaires qui refusent au calme et qui
joue le jeu des violences comme on l'a
vu dans les émeutes c'est inacceptable
je pense que c'est une insulte aussi aux
Français qui sont protégés tous les
jours par cette police sur les
ajustements promis par la première
ministre en tout cas c'est ce qu'elle
souhaite ça devrait être annoncée dans
les prochains jours qu'il faut-il
changer au gouvernement vous savez bien
que c'est pas du tout ma responsabilité
de député de répondre à cela et je fais
confiance au présent la République et la
première ministre je crois que le plus
important c'est de continuer à réformer
le plus important c'est de justement un
gouvernement qui soit plus politique on
a critiqué un peu la société civile
beaucoup de ministres en sont issus
est-ce que ça c'est par exemple une idée
pour changer j'essaie de faire mon
travail de parlementaires je crois qu'il
faut qu'il y en ait des talents qui
viennent de partout on a énormément de
gens qui viennent de la cité civile qui
sont venus enrichir majorité depuis six
ans le plus important c'est qu'on
continue avec un cap réformateur
ambitieux et clair et en tout cas le
gros Renaissance sera là pour soutenir
et travailler avec le gouvernement et
co-construire à l'assemblée
de la majorité disent avoir été
approchés alors pour vous Daniel Simonet
qui faut changer au gouvernement en fait
il faudrait surtout changer toute la
politique mais non changer le fond de la
politique vous savez là le réchauffement
climatique exige vraiment qu'on repense
et bien un protectionnisme un
protectionnisme écologique comprennent
conscience que nos ressources naturelles
sont limitées on a le débat sur
l'industrie verte mais en fait c'est la
macronie verte et le problème c'est pas
la couleur c'est la logique
ultralibérale vous avez les plus riches
dont les profits explosent alors que en
ce moment et bien la misère se développe
ce matin j'étais au Conseil
constitutionnel pour demander et bien la
censure de de cette loi kasparis en
berger qui est vraiment une loi
anti-locataire on a les expulsions
locatives qui explosent nous avons une
misère qui progresse et hélas la
politique de ce gouvernement ne
s'attaque pas à la misère mais essaye de
réprimer les plus pauvres donc il faut
vraiment changer de cap radicalement et
aussi enfin restaurer la démocratie la
démocratie parlementaire et qu'on en
finisse l'année prochaine avec le 49-3
donc vous voyez c'était pas une question
de personnes dans le gouvernement et
dans le remaniement mais d'axe politique
fort dont on souhaiterait voir le
changement alors on verra dès la rentrée
puisque le budget arrivera au mois
d'octobre dans les mystique de
l'Assemblée nationale un mot sur le
président de la République il doit
s'exprimer dans les prochains jours en
tout cas d'ici dimanche que doit-il dire
pour donner confiance aux Français
et je crois qu'il doit continuer
d'expliquer l'action qui a été la nôtre
depuis six ans une action de réarmement
des services publics une action de
diminution du chômage une action de
réindustrialisation du pays l'action
internationale aussi on a toujours une
guerre en Ukraine le président est très
impliqué sur la scène européenne et
internationale et puis tracer les
perspectives des prochaines années
qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous Daniel
Simonet cette prise de parole du
président de la République
écoutez franchement que ce que vous
voulez qu'on en attende on aimerait
qu'il reconnaisse que ça a été une année
catastrophique une année de mépris du
débat démocratique une année ou alors
que le peuple a 80% été mobilisé contre
sa réforme des retraites il n'a rien
voulu entendre une année ou au contraire
il a usé de la répression contre les
manifestants contre les mobilisations
mais je ne pense pas qu'il dira cela ce
soir parlant de l'ordre de son
allocation donc je pense et là ce que
nous n'avons rien à en attendre mais
qu'on sera quand même déçu alors on en
vient maintenant aux conclusions de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
les
uber files Dominique Daniel Simonnet
vous êtes rapporteur de cette commission
d'enquête vous vous en êtes le président
Benjamin Haddad alors pour rappel les
yoga c'est cette fuite massive de
documents internes à l'entreprise
américaine de VTC Hubert en 2022 et qui
porte sur la période 2014 2016 quand
Emmanuel Macron était ministre de
l'Économie Stéphanie Despierre vous avez
suivi la conférence de presse après les
conclusions de cette commission
d'enquête que 10 rapports y a-t-il eu un
deal entre père et Emmanuel Macron alors
qu'il était ministre de l'économie pour
l'insoumise Daniel Simonet c'est oui en
échange de la fermeture de son
application
uberpop la société américaine aurait
obtenu une baisse du nombre d'heures de
formation nécessaire pour les chauffeurs
de VTC donc l'ouverture du marché
français la députée pointe entre 2014 et
2016 des liens extrêmement privilégiés
entre Emmanuel Macron et les dirigeants
du Berre via une série de SMS détaillée
il n'y a pas eu dit-elle de valise
d'échanges de valise de billets mais le
terme d'îles figure dans ses textos
alors ces conclusions ne sont absolument
pas partagées côté majorité c'est un
euphémisme Benjamin Haddad le président
de la commission d'enquête vous l'avez
dit est député Renaissance accuse Daniel
Simonnet d'avoir versé dans le
complotiste de n'avoir apporté aucun
fait nouveau grâce à la commission
d'enquête et d'avoir rédigé un rapport
partisan qui ne tient pas compte des
auditions il rappelle que les ministres
de l'époque et le Premier ministre ont
déclaré qu'il n'avait pas eu
connaissance d'un deal et que se deal
aurait été impossible pour Benjamin
Haddad il n'y a aucune opacité aucune
espèce d'indulgence à l'égard du Berre
dernière précision le principal
intéressé Emmanuel Macron n'a pas été
entendu l'immunité présidentielle en
empêche merci pour ces précisions
Stéphanie Despierre alors Daniel Simonet
Hubert a trouvé des alliés au plus haut
niveau de l'État je lis votre rapport à
l'intensité des contacts entre uber
Emmanuel Macron et son cabinet témoigne
d'une relation opaque mais privilégiée
est-ce que vous pouvez étayer ce que
vous pouvez documenter ses propos alors
d'abord on est face à une multinationale
américaine qui a érigé l'illégalité en
principe de fonctionnement il faut
savoir que c'est une plateforme qui a
bien connaissance qu'elle en fera la loi
mais qui le théorise il y a par exemple
un graphiste assez impressionnant qui
s'appelle The peyramid of sheets et qui
montre à quel point ils assument de
piétiner le cadre légal et malgré toute
cette illégalité vis-à-vis du Code du
travail vis des obligations fiscales de
la concurrence et bien la plateforme va
avoir un interlocuteur privilégié pour
défendre ses intérêts on la personne du
ministre de l'économie de l'époque
Emmanuel Macron et on a plein d'échanges
qui ont été fournis par Marc Magan
l'ancien lobbyiste qui est devenu
lanceur d'alerte qui montre à quel point
il y a eu toute une stratégie conjointe
entre les dirigeants du père et Emmanuel
Macron et son cabinet à coup de
d'amendements clés en main de stratégie
à l'Assemblée pour faire atterrir un
deal qui vise en fait la suppression de
la plateforme uberpop qui était illégal
et pour lequel Hubert avait été condamné
en échange d'un arrêté extrêmement
avantageux pour Hubert parce que ça va
permettre à Hubert de recruter des VTC
formé non pas en 250 heures mais en 7
heures et de pouvoir accéder à un nombre
de sessions illimité alors Emmanuel
Macron était assez minoritaire dans le
gouvernement de l'époque sur ses
positions là néanmoins il va jouer tout
son rôle mais l'importance dans le
rapport c'est que nous continuons aussi
à étudier la période de 2017 a
aujourd'hui justement on en reviendra
plus préoccupant alors Benjamin a
évidemment vous n'avez pas du tout la
même lecture de ces hubert-fight vous
vous ne reconnaissez pas de Deal cachés
entre le nombre d'heures ABC pour les
chauffeurs uber et l'arrêter de ber pop
par exemple pas d'accord privilégié
entre Hubert et Emmanuel Macron vous
savez d'abord nous on sait jamais opposé
à la création de cette commission
d'enquête et d'ailleurs on sait pas
opposé à sa publication on n'a pas voté
compte pourquoi parce que depuis le
début on dit qu'il n'y a absolument rien
à cacher qu'Emmanuel Macron comme les
autres ministres du gouvernement étaient
dans leur rôle face à un nouveau
phénomène les VTC qui sont venus
bouleverser un marché des taxis qui
était très réglementés où il y avait une
pénurie d'offres et c'était un service
qui posait des questions réglementaires
législatives auxquelles il fallait
répondre on a auditionné tous les
acteurs de l'époque qu'est-ce qui nous
ont dit sous serment qui a pas eu de
deal qui a pas eu de connivence
d'opacité ou de contrepartie ils l'ont
dit sincèrement que ce soit Bernard Caz
l'ancien Premier ministre Manuel Valls à
l'invidalise des opposants comme Bernard
Cazeneuve a Emmanuel Macron que ce soit
le lanceur d'alerte du beurre monsieur
Marc Magan quand je lis le dossier de la
rapporteur on dit le deal a bien eu lieu
ce deal il est démenti par Bernard
Cazeneuve et par le lanceur d'alerte
monsieur Marc Morgan je vois à la page
suivante le cabinet de Macron à
Cazeneuve vont coopérer pour modifier
l'arrêté de Marseille le préfet de
police comme Bernard Cazeneuve ont
démenti sous serment et d'ailleurs c'est
pas vrai puisque c'est arrêté est revenu
deux jours après et il a été élargi son
périmètre a été élargi donc durci contre
les VTC je vois la page suivante le
financement de la campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron pose question Monsieur Marc Magan
qui devait admirer Emmanuel Macron après
avoir quitté
über a décidé de participer à des
soirées des financement la campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron
il a été en contact avec Emmanuel Macron
évidemment dans les limites légales des
dons qu'aucun dirigeant du beurre
n'avait participé et qui ne l'a pas fait
sous pression du beurre c'est quelqu'un
qui est aujourd'hui en conflit avec uber
c'est le lanceur d'Alep qui a révélé les
124 000 documents internes de l'enquête
il dit et pourtant la rapporteur dit ah
il y a quand même toujours des questions
des questions se posent c'est un rapport
en fait à charge partisans qui dénature
le rôle des commissions bancaires et qui
était écrit avant même les auditions les
conclusions étaient connues avant et moi
je voudrais juste poser une question
très simple si ce récit ne tient que si
Bernard case neuve un préfet de police
des ministres et le lanceur d'alerte
lui-même on menti sous serment et bien
pourquoi vous n'en tirez pas les
conclusions et à ce moment là vous
faites un signalement au procureur au
titre de l'article 40 puisque ça engage
leur responsabilité pénale vous ne le
faites pas puisqu'en fait ce que vous
faites c'est que vous sous-entendez
qu'ils ont menti ils ont tirer les
conclusions mais vous n'osez pas le dire
ouvertement parce que vous seriez obligé
d'aller devant le procure et vous ne
voulez pas le faire est-ce que vous avez
fait de la politique finalement vous
allez pas tellement plus loin que la
relation des ubershe le rôle c'est pas
purement de la politique et de contrôler
l'exécutif et c'est ça de la politique
et c'est très noble alors d'abord les
travaux de la commission d'enquête
parlementaire ont été empêchés il faut
le dire puisque monsieur le Président
Benjamin Hadad a refusé que la
commission d'enquête puisse auditionner
les membres du cabinet d'Emmanuel Macron
de l'époque et notamment monsieur bureau
alors à la fin des auditions alors que
je n'avais toujours pas obtenu cette
cette droite de auditionné les membres
du cabinet d'Emmanuel Macron sachant que
on ne pouvait pas auditionner Emmanuel
Macron et bien monsieur le Président a
refusé les auditions des des je voudrais
terminer s'il vous plaît
concernant les documents des
hubert-faces les documents
franchement incontestable vous
regarderez dans le rapport qui est
public l'ensemble des échanges de mails
de messages de SMS entre Emmanuel Macron
lui-même et Travis calanic le PDG du
beurre entre les membres de la direction
du Berre et d'autres membres du cabinet
il y a bien utile par contre ce qui est
vrai c'est que le deal entre Emmanuel
Macron est dirigeants du maire s'est
fait un insu du gouvernement concernant
par contre l'arrêté des Bouches-du-Rhône
on a bien à la fois des échanges de
messages ou Hubert exige de d'Emmanuel
Macron demande à Emmanuel Macron de
d'intervenir et Monsieur Manuel Macron
répond qu'il va personnellement s'en
charger face à un arrêté qui était
défavorable à Hubert et on a des
échanges qui n'avaient pas été transmis
par la presse de dirigeants du Berre
avec Monsieur Bernard avec le cabinet de
Monsieur Bernard Cazeneuve et qui vont
aboutir au retrait du premier arrêté
pour un deuxième arrêté beaucoup plus
favira favorable il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque il y a une grève des taxis très
forte sur les gares et les aéroport la
loi interdit aux plateformes
uber de de venir sur les gares et les
aéroports c'est la loi tfnou et le
message en fait du préfet de l'époque
était pour calmer les taxis et montrer
qu'on allait faire des opérations de
contrôle et le deuxième arrêté ne cite
plus berrics et si tous les bourgeons
donc finalement ça va pas du Berry les
taxis ça va pertinemment à l'époque le
taxi savent pertinemment s'est arrêté
est-ce que vous avez des questions si
vous me laissez si vous pas vous
répondre à vos questions pour engager la
responsabilité pénale
si ça le dérange de terminer son propos
alors terminé la question de Benjamin
donc les taxis sont furax parce qu'ils
savent bien qu'ils ont été trahis par
cet arrêté sauf que que dit Monsieur
Bernard Cazeneuve dans l'audition lors
de l'audition Cazeneuve nous n'avons pas
ces éléments de marque Magan de ses
échanges monsieur Cazeneuve dit juste je
n'ai pas subi de pression de Monsieur
Emmanuel Macron sur le changement de ces
arrêtés donc il a pas évidemment il a
fait un mensonge par omission s'il vous
plaît parce que il ne dit pas il ne dit
pas que les membres de son cabinet
étaient en lien direct avec les
dirigeants du Berre pour faire modifier
cet arrêté donc et là j'ai bien peur que
je ne puisse pas par l'article 40 par
contre ce qui est très important dans ce
rapport c'est que nous avons depuis 2017
un gouvernement ou des gouvernements
Macron qui sont pleinement au courant de
l'étendue et du développement de
l'ubérisation il y a une note excellente
de 2019 du ministère des du travail qui
montre cette étendu et qui insiste sur
l'illégalité des plateformes vis-à-vis
du Code du travail vis-à-vis des
obligations fiscales vis-à-vis de
l'URSSAF vis-à-vis de la concurrence
vis-à-vis des professions réglementées
alors on se dit toutes les notes par la
suite vont montrer à quel point il faut
respecter les données
qui nécessite sur ce registre là nous
n'avons jamais été sur ce registre là ce
qui est grave ici c'est que le rôle d'un
gouvernement est fait pour faire
respecter l'état de droit
sous forme de conflit d'intérêt la
directive européenne elle a été adoptée
par les États membres donc il faut
mettre à jour vos éléments de langage
elle a été adoptée il n'y a aucun
conflit d'intérêt et que ce soit Bernard
Cazeneuve Manuel Valls sous le lanceur
d'alerte ils ont dit ils ont 12 ans par
exemple nous avons une réunion hier avec
le Premier ministre monsieur Cazeneuve a
calmer les taxis je vais réunir tout le
monde la semaine prochaine pour préparer
la réforme et corriger la loi monsieur
kaisnove a accepté le deal c'est un SMS
de Monsieur Macron mais bien sûr mais il
avait il avait un diable débat alors
au sein du gouvernement mais ça
monsieur vidalis ils l'ont tous affirmé
il y avait à ce moment-là du
gouvernement sur la meilleure façon de
trouver l'équilibre entre la création
d'emploi l'innovation l'accompagnement
de ces nouvelles formes de mobilité et
les taxis il y avait aussi d'ailleurs
des mobilisations qui étaient parfois
violentes on voit dans le rapport de
Madame Simonet un alignement total sur
les positions des lobbies des taxis elle
affirme par exemple qu'à l'époque de
l'arrivée des VTC il y avait aucun
problème de taxi à Paris il y avait pas
de pénurie d'offres comparé à New York
lond Madrid ça a été démontré par B2
rapports
il y avait un problème de pénurie
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on a trouvé un
équilibre qui satisfait tout le monde
que ce soit les représentants
la preuve c'est le SMS de Macron
qui a été signé par mystère de
l'Intérieur mystère des transports et
mystères d'économie le ministre des
Transports de l'époque Monsieur
vidaliste critique du beurre nous dit
qu'il a durci les conditions pourquoi il
a durci les conditions parce qu'en fait
il n'y avait pas d'examen il y avait
juste un nombre d'heures et personne
respectée donc on dit on passe de 250 à
7h en fait on a créé un examen on a créé
un examen et on a aligné les conditions
d'accès entre les taxis avec les 90%
de ces plateformes parce que elle est
contre la création d'emploi que ça peut
apporter les contre la l'offre que ça
peut apporter pour les utilisateurs et
en fait elle s'aligne sur les
propositions des taxis il y a plusieurs
propositions alors la première
proposition du rapport c'est la
révocation des élus ça on voit pas trop
le rapport mais bon c'est de la France
insoumise et après il y a des
propositions qui reprennent texto les
propositions des lobbies des taxis moi
j'aimerais demander à Madame Simonet si
elle est pour la transparence combien de
temps combien de fois vous avez
rencontré les lobbys des taxis cette
année est-ce que monsieur delogu qui est
votre collègue de la France insoumise de
la commission enquête qui s'exprime
toujours en tant que porte-parole des
taxis est-ce qu'il a porté les
propositions des taxis dans cette ce
rapport de la commission d'enquête voilà
il y a effectivement une vision assez
assez complexe effectivement des
différences mais légitimes sincère sur
un débat complexe
sur l'équilibre à trouver entre
l'innovation et la régulation il y a une
volonté de les attribuer à des
influences opaque à des connivences et
tout ça n'est jamais prouvé jamais
démontré et nos auditions à l'inverse
ont démontré le contraire alors au-delà
de ça est-ce qu'il faut pas réguler
mieux réguler le lobbying c'est une des
préconisations par exemple il y a une
urgence à organiser la séparation des
lobbies et de l'État et on sait que avec
la macronie on a quand même plus un
dossier qui est extrêmement
problématique que ce soit l'affaire
coller que ce soit
l'affaire sans récente qu'on va avoir
ferrachi sur la problématique de France
travail ou le scandale qui vient de
tomber aujourd'hui sur la Bible
toutes les accusations des lobbies de
l'État déjà on constate que la loi Sapin
2 a des décrets d'applications qui ne
vont pas du tout il faut absolument
exiger des gouvernements des ministres
mais aussi des parlementaires qu'ils
rendent public à leur agenda tout leur
rencontre avec les lobbies et puis nous
estimons que il y a réfléchir pour
rendre public l'origine des amendements
vous savez quand moi j'interviens sur
les questions de droit au logement
j'assume dans l'hémicycle de défendre un
amendement qui m'a été par exemple
proposé par la Fondation Abbé Pierre
pourquoi et bien lorsque les macronistes
interviennent dans l'hémicycle il
n'assument pas d'avoir des amendements
qui sont défendus par Hubert qui sont du
copier-coller de Total qui sont du COP
coller de gros intérêts privés il faut
de la transparence dans tout cela et
nous proposons par exemple une
plateforme citoyenne qui permettra aussi
à l'ensemble des collectifs citoyens
associations syndicats de pouvoir donner
connaissance et bien des amendements qui
proposent au texte de loi Benjamin
est-ce qu'il faudrait publier tout
simplement les rencontres entre les
représentants d'intérêt et les membres
du gouvernement par exemple alors moi je
suis pas du tout opposé à plus de
transparence dans les agendas des
parlementaires des ministres la
plateforme citoyenne de dépôt
d'amendement dont parle Daniel Simonet
j'y suis pas non plus opposé il y a eu
quand même beaucoup de progrès qui ont
été fait ces dernières années avec la
loi Sapin 2 et la création du registre
de la hlvp la transparence donc notre
pays va déjà un peu plus loin que
d'autres mais il y a des modèles dont on
pourrait s'inspirer comme la Suède le
problème en fait quand on lit rapport
c'est pas le lobbying c'est que Madame
Simonet veut nous faire croire qu'on
peut gouverner un pays sans voir les
acteurs économiques sans échanger sans
avoir leur point de vue sans qu'on peut
les réguler sans comprendre leur
problématique
il était dans son rôle en rencontrant
les acteurs économiques et en les
accompagnant elle se fait en fait le
porte-parole d'autres lobbies se détaxi
dans cette affaire en disant que
Monsieur
mais les chauffeurs VTC mais vos
propositions c'est très intéressant vos
propositions totalement à l'encontre des
représentants des chauffeurs les
chauffeurs VTC ont dit qu'il voulait le
dialogue social les chauffeurs VTC on
vous dit qu'il voulait voir leurs droits
revalorisés au sein du dialogue social
nous faisons des propositions
la loi va évoluer de ce point de vue là
alors ce que nous proposons c'est déjà
de prendre des mesures de renforcement
de la lutte contre la fraude en
particulier des plateformes de livraison
nous invitons aussi les plateformes à
s'engager pleinement dans le dialogue
social qui a été mis en place par le
gouvernement pour avoir des avancées sur
le revenu minimum il y en a déjà eu
quelques-unes mais on peut aller plus
loin sur la direction sociale sur le
droit à la déconnexion sur la protection
des données privées ce gouvernement
c'est le premier en Europe à avoir mis
en place un cadre de dialogue social
avec des représentants un des
plateformes des représentants
c'est nous qui avons apporté cette
avancée sociale maintenant effectivement
il faut qu'il y a encore plus d'avancer
sinon le législateur prendra ses
responsabilités
un pro uber qui a été payé par Hubert et
avec la participation aux élections qui
est complètement
sur ce plateau on passe à présent au
focus dans cette émission
[Musique]
et des députés vont proposer une
proposition de loi pour protéger la
liberté éditoriale des médias après la
grève déclenchée au JDD sur la
nomination de Geoffroy Lejeune à sa tête
derrière c'est l'interventionnisme de
Vincent Bolloré qui est dénoncé
Stéphanie despiat vous êtes au côté de
Sophie tailler polliant qui est député
écologiste du Val-de-Marne qui est
signataire de ce texte bonjour Alors
vous voulez favoriser l'indépendance des
rédactions qu'est-ce que vous proposez
pour garantir l'indépendance des
rédaction nous proposons de donner un
droit un droit d'agrément aux
journalistes pour qu'ils puissent en cas
de modification de changement de leur
directeur de rédaction pouvoir s'y
opposer pourquoi parce que le directeur
de rédaction c'est quand même lui qui
permet à une ambiance de travail qui
garantit le respect de la déontologie et
aussi de l'honnêteté journalistique si
des journalistes considèrent que tel ou
telle personnalité ne peut pas garantir
cela c'est leur travail la qualité de
leur travail qu'on remet en cause et là
en l'espèce parce que cette proposition
de loi vient bien sûr
réaction nouvelle nouveau coup d'éclat
de Monsieur Bolloré pour prendre pour
avoir la main mise sur les médias en
France Monsieur Geoffroy Lejeune qu'il
propose de mettre à la tête de la
rédaction du JDD ne peut garantir en
aucun cas le respect de la déontologie
et en aucun cas l'honnêteté
intellectuelle et journalistique parce
qu'il roule pour un ancien candidat à la
présidentielle il roule pour un parti
donc ça voudrait dire que si les
journalistes s'opposent à l'arrivée d'un
directeur de la rédaction le directeur
la rédaction ne peut pas prendre son
poste est-ce que ce n'est pas s'immiscer
dans la vie d'une entreprise ces données
un pouvoir particulier à des salariés
qui exercent un métier particulier
l'information c'est un une pierre
indispensable à la démocratie donc les
journalistes exercent un métier
particulier donc leur donner ce droit de
protéger l'exercice dans le cadre de la
déontologie de leur métier c'est
indispensable à la démocratie ce n'est
pas du tout remettre en cause la
capacité
d'un actionnaire de prendre des parts
dans un dans un média mais juste
d'acheter un média et de le mettre à sa
main en fonction de ses idées c'est tout
vous expliquer tout à l'heure c'est une
première pierre pour une avancée de la
liberté de la presse qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire d'autre pour la garantir
mieux en France aujourd'hui bien sûr
qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres choses à
faire et qui devront être faites le plus
rapidement possible pour que dans notre
pays la pluralité des médias leur
indépendance soit raffermie on a
aujourd'hui un problème majeur de
concentration des médias entre les mains
de quelques actionnaires dont certains
d'entre eux dont Monsieur Bolloré ont un
projet politique
les rédactions sont soumises à ce projet
de mise en avant d'idées d'extrême
droite et qu'est-ce qui se passe
monsieur Bolloré met de moins en moins
de journalistes et de plus en plus
d'éditorialistes donc c'est bien est-ce
que ces médias sont des journaux ou
est-ce que ce sont des officiers
sophistes de communication qui est la
question avec la proposition de loi et
bien finalement il faudra choisir
si on se positionne en tant que journal
et bien on doit avoir un doigt
d'arguments et donner des droits au
journaliste un dernier mot rapide cette
proposition de loi est déposée par des
députés de tous les groupes à
l'exception du RN et des républicains
quand est-ce que vous espérez qu'elle
soit discutée ici écoutez-le plutôt sera
le mieux nous soutenons la le mouvement
social la grève depuis 4 semaines
maintenant des journalistes du JDD il ne
faut pas un nouveau JDD donc le plus tôt
sera le mieux dès que possible en
fonction du calendrier de l'Assemblée
nationale merci
si vous nous rejoignez sur LCP sachez
que nous sommes à présent à 23 minutes
des questions au gouvernement que vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur LCP à partir de 15
heures alors pour vous faire vivre toute
cette actualité cette dernière séance de
questions au Gouvernement aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée vous retrouverez elles à
Gava et Stéphanie desperres qui se
trouve celle des quatre colonnes nous
retrouvons également Marco pommier qui
est en les tribunes de l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale pour le menu des
questions au gouvernement et puis nous
vous ferons vivre à partir de 14h45
14h50 l'arrivée de la première ministre
est de tous les membres du gouvernement
c'est par l'entrée principale du palais
Bourbon c'est-à-dire elle a cours
d'honneur alors on va tout de suite
retrouver Marco pommier qui se trouve
lui déjà dans les tribunes Marco deux
thèmes aujourd'hui qui se dégagent de
cette séance
oui un deux thèmes qui s'impose avec
d'abord la santé sur la fermeture des
urgences notamment à des urgences sous
haute tension cet été en raison du
manque de soignants on parlera aussi de
la situation des EHPAD en période
estivale et puis de la santé mentale des
jeunes autre thème le coût de l'énergie
les tarifs de l'électricité vont grimper
de 10% au premier août prochain pour un
ménage en moyenne ça représenterait 150
euros de plus par an soit 13 euros par
mois c'est cette étape c'est une ex ce
n'est qu'une étape dans la fin
progressive du bouclier tarifaire il
s'arrêtera à la fin de l'année 2024
et voilà et pendant que vous parlez
Marco il y a la garde républicaine qui
arrive juste derrière moi avec ses
tambours la revue des troupes va avoir
lieu dans quelques instants elle est
trop en bourse sont déjà prêt pour
accueillir la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale Marco on revient sur les
autres thèmes qui sont abordés tout à
l'heure dans l'émission avec vous
oui à Brigitte les députés reviendront
aussi sur les annonces d'Élisabeth borne
autour de la sécurité routière hier la
première ministre a annoncé 38 mesures
dont la création d'une nouvelle
infraction l'homicide routier on
retiendra aussi la suspension
automatique du permis en cas de conduite
sous l'emprise de stupéfiants et puis la
drogue au volant maintenant ce sera huit
points de permis de 8 points de retirer
sur le permis pardonnez-moi contre 6
actuellement à noter aussi Brigitte la
première question d'Adrien catenens
depuis sa réintégration dans le groupe
de la France insoumise il en avait été
exclu après avoir été condamné pour
violence conjugale sur son ex-compagne
il posera une question cet après-midi
sur la France qu'il considère comme un
paradis fiscal pour les riches voilà le
programme merci pour ce programme
complet donc première question d'Adrien
Catena au sein du groupe elle est fit
depuis qu'il est revenu j'accueille à
présent sur ce plateau Olga givernais
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député
reconnaissance de l'un et anapick
bonjour vous êtes députés socialiste et
apparentés de la Manche alors vous le
savez sur LCP il y a les questions au
Gouvernement et puis il y a aussi des
questions des citoyens s'ils étaient eux
dans l'hémicycle cet après-midi quelle
question il poserait aux membres du
gouvernement alors je vous propose
d'entendre Stanislas il a 24 ans et il
est étudiant
bonjour je m'appelle stenlave juillet je
suis diplômée du Collège d'Europe j'ai
étudié les affaires européennes dans ce
cas j'aimerais poser une question au
ministreur de l'environnement l'Europe
souhaite être le premier continent
neutre sur le plan climatique à
l'horizon 2050 dans ce cadre j'aimerais
vous poser la question la France était
le prête à respecter ces engagements en
matière de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique est-elle prête à rehausser
ses objectifs merci beaucoup
l'objectif de neutralité carbone c'est
en 2050 Olga givernais est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on est prêt à y arriver ce que
la trajectoire va nous permettre de le
faire la France est très moteur sur ce
sujet d'ailleurs on est en pleine
préparation de la loi de programmation
énergique climat avec la ministre de la
transition énergétique et l'objectif
évidemment c'est de tenir nos objectifs
de 2050 mais c'est aussi de faire des
paliers à 2030 et moi j'aimerais aussi à
2000 à 2040 ce qui nous permettra
d'accélérer notamment sur les objectifs
de décoration et de transition
énergétique vous y croyez anapi qu'à
cette trajectoire quand vous pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas de signes
extrêmement positifs il faut reconnaître
que la France a été condamnée par deux
fois pour inaction climatique que nous
ne pouvons que constater que le projet
de loi pour l'accélération des énergies
nouvelles renouvelables n'allez pas
aussi loin que nous l'aurions souhaité
et que nous avons vu surtout au
contraire la mise en place de fin de
régulation et notamment du point de
l'environnemental et là aujourd'hui nous
sommes en train cette semaine d'étudier
le projet industrie verte qui n'a de
vertes que le titre puisque en réalité
nous n'arrivons pas à faire en sorte que
le gouvernement définit cette industrie
verte et qu'il donne des objectifs
concrets concernant notamment le
verdissement de notre industrie mais
aussi l'objectif et comment atteindre
l'objectif de notre réalité carbone ce
qu'on entend c'est qu'il y a un peu de
greenwashing dans ce gouvernement
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à un
applique c'est vrai que sur la loi
industrie verte on a des débats très
très importants et l'objectif c'est que
chacun puisse prendre sa part au niveau
de l'État au niveau des entreprises au
niveau aussi des collectivités
territoriales l'objectif c'est de
pouvoir faciliter ces implantations de
d'entreprise on connaît les gigafactory
pour les batteries électriques tout ce
qui va nous permettre de transitionner
et bien nous devons pouvoir le faciliter
dans dans cette loi et puis il y a eu
les lois aussi pour la facilitation
d'implantation du nucléaire les lois sur
les EnR précédemment et donc il faut
utiliser ces véhicules à chaque fois
pour ce qu'ils sont
d'utilité et donc nous nous croyons
vraiment que cette planification cet
engagement va donner des résultats très
rapidement je l'espère il faut de se
donner des objectifs aussi par exemple
moi je travaille sur la sobriété
émergétique l'objectif est aussi de
réduire notre consommation d'énergie
d'éviter notre demande en énergie
fossile et surtout aussi les carburants
c'est des c'est des points à discuter il
faut le faire dans la concertation il y
a une vraie demande de justice sociale à
ce niveau-là quand on vient en soutien
par des chèques énergies notamment sur
le gaz et bien il faut le faire aussi
dans cette perspective que nous voulons
sortir des énergies financières il
faudrait pas que la planification ne
reste qu'un élément de communication et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas les signes
qui permettent de dire ça lorsqu'on
planifie on ne dérégule pas au contraire
on a des stratégies qui visent à
atteindre des objectifs et aujourd'hui
nous le voyons nous n'avons ni objectif
ni mais nous faisons confiance plutôt à
des investissements venus de l'extérieur
ce qui est très bien de faire aussi
d'avoir des investissements venus
extérieurs ça n'est pas la question la
question c'est où est l'état stratège où
est la planification où est la
bifurcation que nous attendons comment
vous ne voyez pas les efforts par le
gouvernement tout est dans la fin de
réalisation est un point que les camps
français ont compris nous avons besoin
de produire chez nous c'est bon pour le
porte-monnaie c'est bon aussi pour notre
souveraineté et ça c'est une neutralité
carbone aussi
on va et les oppositions sont
constamment en train de de dénigrer ces
orientations et donc ça ça met alors
vous nous parliez du du chèque énergie
il y a quelques instants on va parler à
présent de la fin du bouclier tarifaire
parce que ça inquiète les députés il y
aura évidemment des questions cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale pourquoi parce que
les coûts de l'électricité les tarifs
ont augmenté de 10% au 1er août à
annoncer ce matin le gouvernement deux
questions sur ce sujet on va écouter
Sébastien Petavy qui est député
écologiste de la Dordogne et qui est au
micro d'Elsa mendingava oui plus 10%
d'augmentation ça pourrait représenter
plus de 150 euros annuels sur la facture
ça vous inquiète qu'est-ce que vous
attendez du gouvernement bien sûr que
c'est inquiétant pour beaucoup de foyers
puisque les on a pu le voir entre le
l'augmentation de l'essence les salaires
le SMIC qui a peu augmenté et donc on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec les mêmes
personnes et notamment les plus
précaires qui vont devoir supporter
encore une fois cette augmentation et il
y a de quoi être inquiet alors le
gouvernement se justifie en disant ce
bouclier tarifaire il a déjà coûté
énormément d'argent il fallait bien y
mettre fin il met fin par étape est-ce
que c'est pas entendable
nous on leur avait posé la question
quand il a été mis en place est-ce que
on doit l'appliquer pour tout le monde
est-ce que les 10% les plus riches qui
consomment 20 fois plus que les 10% les
plus pauvres doivent avoir le même
bouclier et en fait le problème est là
ça a été dans ce qui a été mis en place
dès le départ après la grande question
quand on voit le peu de moyens qui ont
été mis pour la rénovation thermique par
exemple en fait il y a un choix
structurel et on voit que encore une
fois le gouvernement est incapable de
prévoir d'anticiper et de protéger les
plus fragiles dernière question
peut-être que ce sera la réponse du
gouvernement vous le savez aussi le
gouvernement veut relancer le parc
nucléaire ce sera de l'électricité moins
cher on sait que les Verts ça a pas été
toujours facile sur cette question
est-ce que vous vous attendez à avoir
cette remarque la grande question est
doit-on garder le même niveau de
consommation et donc pour nous
clairement il va falloir faire des
économies dans la consommation d'énergie
et ont proposé nous justement un tarif
progressif et donc pour que les
consommations on va dire courantes pour
chauffer pour se nourrir pour se laver
soit beaucoup moins cher et que pour
ceux qui ont des consommations on va
dire superflues payent beaucoup plus
cher ce qui inciterait à ces personnes
là aussi à moins consommer donc voilà le
la logique qui serait en fait une bonne
chose et pour la planète et pour les
plus précaires merci beaucoup cette
annonce un de l'augmentation de
l'électricité elle fait réagir on
entendra tout à l'heure donc le
gouvernement à ce sujet il y aura aussi
une question d'un député RN sur ce sur
ce sujet Olga givernais vous avez
entendu monsieur Petavy l'inquiétude
c'est cette facture qui augmente pour
les français alors que l'inflation est
déjà très forte et cette fin du bouclier
tarifaire finalement est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas face à une nouvelle taxe
carbone qui va vous exploser à la figure
dans quelques mois alors la question de
l'énergie inquiète évidemment tout le
monde nous les premiers et lorsque l'on
voit le gouvernement qui a plafonné
cette augmentation à 10% elle aurait pu
être à 75% comme la recommandée la
Commission de régulation de de l'énergie
et bien il a encore une protection forte
des des
usagers par rapport à cette augmentation
après moi quand j'ai les écologistes qui
viennent nous donner des leçons alors
que ils ont abandonné le nucléaire qui
est cette énergie la plus décarbonée qui
va nous permettre de qui nous a permis
aussi de passer l'hiver et bien et bien
j'ai un peu du mal à les comprendre il
faut savoir que les chèques énergies
sont là jusqu'à fin 2024 les Français
ont vu les efforts fait par l'État pour
pouvoir les protéger ils savent aussi
très bien que les 40 milliards d'euros
que nous avons
investi de cette manière là et bien
elles ne peuvent pas durer ad vitam
æternam il faut trouver d'autres
solutions je vous parlais de la sobriété
mais aussi de la façon dont nous allons
produire et faire baisser ensuite le
coup de ces énergies c'est un objectif
que nous avons bien bien en tête alors
un applique le bouclier tarifaire va
s'arrêter progressivement on le voit là
déjà début août et puis jusqu'à la fin
2024 vous êtes inquiète pour le
porte-monnaie des Français evidemment
qu'on est inquiet je suis aussi une élue
locale et je l'ai été longtemps et
aujourd'hui on sait combien de personnes
défilent dans les CCAS dans les centres
communaux d'action sociale parce que
évidemment déjà en janvier avec
l'augmentation de 10%, il y avait eu des
grosses difficultés puis n'oublions pas
que c'est 10% lorsqu'on bénéficie du
bouclier tarifaire mais certains chez
les bailleurs sociaux effectivement des
locataires qui étaient forts avaient vu
leur augmentation bien plus importante
que ça et puis la question je veux dire
on peut caricaturer notre propos au sur
la question du nucléaire ce qui est en
ce qui me concerne totalement fallacieux
puisque en l'occurrence la question que
nous posons c'est celle du mix
énergétique et de la manière dont nous
pouvons équilibrer les choses le
nucléaire comme d'autres énergies posent
des questions à laquelle auxquelles nous
devons répondre le vrai problématique
aujourd'hui c'est celle du marché de
l'électricité notamment qui fait que à
la fois notre entreprise publique le
fleuron industriel que nous avons
construit c'est les Français qui l'ont
construit ce Florent industriel perd de
l'argent se trouve extrêmement endetté
et dans le même temps nous avons un coup
de l'électricité qui ne cesse de monter
pour l'ensemble des Français nous avions
posé cette question
nucléaire c'était une erreur ça coûte
trop cher
c'était une erreur nous essayons de
construire un mix énergétique qui puisse
combiner la question sociale et la
question écologique et c'est toute la
question et c'est toutes les réponses
que nous devons apporter sans
caricaturer ni les objectifs de la
majorité ni nos propres objectifs et je
crois qu'il serait de bon ton sur ces
questions là sur lesquelles
effectivement une réflexion est engagée
mais nous parlons encore de transition
mais ça fait 20 ans que nous parlons de
transition alors à un moment il faut
qu'on aboutisse et la réalité c'est que
répondre de manière simpliste
caricaturale et politicienne ne peut
certainement pas apporter de réponses
concrètes aux Français qui effectivement
vont voir leur porte-monnaie encore
amputé d'une grande partie et c'est leur
quotidien lorsqu'on fait un travail sur
l'inflation évidemment le panier moyen
si on y incorpore l'ordinateur et la
voiture l'inflation ne paraît pas très
haute mais si on regarde la réalité du
quotidien des Français qui ont le plus
besoin de de cette France et de cette et
bien l'augmentation pour eux de leur
quotidien est beaucoup plus importante
l'inflation est beaucoup plus importante
alors on vous entend bien je précise
qu'il y a la sonnerie parce qu'elle est
14h50
la réalité des débats on nous dit on
veut un missionnaire je sais qui est en
fait quand on est dans les débats dans
l'hémicycle et bien si on parle du
nucléaire on perd toute la gauche et il
ne souhaite pas voter avec nous
lorsqu'on parle des énergies
renouvelables et bien il y a une grosse
partie de la droite et de l'extrême
droite qui ne sont pas avec nous je
crois que si on a des belles paroles
comme ça sur le le mix le mix
énergétique et bien il faut aussi que
les votes puissent suivre et qu'on
trouve des coalitions qui permettent de
faire passer un peu plus vite que ce
soit sur l'annonce des tarifs
progressifs de l'électricité ce qu'il
faut pas accélérer un peu là-dessus
accélérer aussi sur le mix énergétique
tout ça on a l'impression effectivement
que ça prend du temps en fait oui parce
que le tarif de l'énergie et de
l'électricité et aussi discuter au
niveau européen et là il faut qu'on
trouve une une convergence sur sur ce
prix là on parle le prix de l'arène du
et il faut pouvoir trouver aussi des
événements toujours corrélés à celui du
gaz et que vous ne souhaitez pas
remettre en cause en fonction en fait
d'un équilibre dans un nouveau marché
économique qui fonctionne la reine
fonctionnait par le passé on était tous
très contents d'avoir des prix régulés
qui nous permettaient d'avoir un prix de
l'électricité très bas aujourd'hui bien
on voit que avec l'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie le gaz qui tire également
ce c'est prix là il faut repenser notre
modèle de prix pour pour nos habitants
pour nos Français on va parler à présent
du remaniement puisque Elizabeth borne a
été maintenue à Matignon annonce de
l'Élysée hier soir il y aura une
question cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle
du député socialiste de Seine-et-Marne
Olivier Faure on le retrouve tout de
suite au micro de Stéphanie desperres
bonjour l'île Lefort qu'allez-vous
demander au gouvernement cet après-midi
tout simplement ce qu'il entend à faire
pour nous apaiser puisque il y avait 100
jours qui étaient destiné à l'apaisement
général on a connu 100 jours
d'embrasement et qu'on aimerait
comprendre maintenant ce qui justifie le
fait que Madame bornes reste à Matignon
puisque visiblement même si ça a été
fait sans aucune publicité et bien on
comprend qu'elle va rester et qu'elle va
même opérer un ajustement technique
d'ailleurs les ajuster technique
apprécieront mais voilà donc pourquoi
faire en fait quel est le sens de cette
renouvellement de bail alors même que on
a un pays qui est sous tension comme
jamais ou aucun des objectifs qui sont
fixés que ce soit sur le réchauffement
climatique que ce soit sur l'inflation
que ce soit sur la sécurité que ce soit
sur l'apaisement dans les quartiers rien
n'est tenu et donc on aimerait
comprendre en fait quels sont les
motivations même borne il y a eu des
discussions des rumeurs sur la
nomination d'un Premier ministre plus à
droite sur même coalition avec les
républicains là Elisabeth borne reste en
poste est-ce que pour vous les
socialistes ce n'est pas un moindre mal
je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a moindre mal
de toute façon je crains que quel que
soit l'identité de celui ou celle qui
sera à Matignon après madame borne ça ne
change pas grand chose puisque tout le
monde l'a compris le pouvoir sous
Emmanuel Macron il n'est pas à Matignon
il est à l'Élysée et donc l'identité de
celui ou celle qui porte responsabilité
de venir chaque semaine répondre aux
questions en réalité assez indifférente
merci beaucoup
Olga givernais Olivier Ford dit ce n'est
pas son jour d'apaisement c'est 100
jours d'embrasement finalement est-ce
qu'elle mérite d'être maintenu à
Matignon la première ministre alors je
crois qu'il n'a pas vraiment suivi
l'actualité il y a eu des émeutes
effectivement ils ont été contenus sur
sur 5 jours et les habits bornes mérite
de pouvoir renouveler avoir la confiance
renouvelée du président de la République
elle a démontré sa capacité à comprendre
et à porter ses dossiers au-delà du
symbole qu'elle ait d'une femme première
ministre que nous soutenons au sein de
la majorité et je crois que c'est un
choix un peu par défaut finalement et je
crois qu'on a besoin aussi dénominateur
commun le changer régulièrement
déstabiliser les interlocuteurs que nous
avons je crois que ça ne ça ne fait pas
avancer le pays vous savez nous on a vu
quand même passer en tant que député
plusieurs ministres dans les
gouvernements lorsqu'on entame un
travail de longue haleine une réforme ça
se fait sur plusieurs mois plusieurs
années et bien nous avons besoin aussi
de cette possibilités je crois
qu'Olivier Faure pour lui ce sera un
moindre mal d'avoir gardé et Elisabeth
borne peut-être que ça l'aurait arrangé
d'avoir un ministre un premier ministre
beaucoup plus à droite comme ça il
aurait pu encore taper plus fort mais
dans les temps où nous sommes la
concorde nationale et ce vers quoi nous
devons tendre et Isabelle borne elle
vient plutôt de la gauche et anapi
finalement est-ce que vous avez pas à
prendre à la connaître au fil des mois
ça fait déjà un an qu'elle est là vous
allez pas nouer plus de Deal finalement
l'année prochaine de dire on vient de
quelque part on vient tous de quelque
part l'important c'est ce qu'on fait au
quotidien et en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est capable direction politique et
Elisabeth borne évidemment c'est un
moindre mal comme l'a dit Olivier fort
puisque c'est la collaboratrice
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était une haute
fonctionnaire c'est toujours une haute
fonctionnaire elle applique ce qu'on lui
demande nous n'avons pas direction
politique et je ne pouvais pas parler de
journée d'apaisement ni de concorde il
n'y a pas de concorde je crois que la
moindre chose peut aujourd'hui faire en
sorte que les mouvements sociaux
reviennent que à nouveau nous soyons
dans la nous tenons aucune réponse ni au
sein de l'assemblée ni les syndicats ne
tiennent pas plus de réponses
aujourd'hui on appelle concertation des
choses qui sont je vous je vous présente
après les émeutes la première ligne à
retrouver les syndicats à Matignon il y
a quelques jours donc ne disons pas la
situation s'est apaisée régulièrement je
ne dis pas que la situation était
meilleure avant loin de là je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron est au pouvoir depuis six ans que
nous avons une première ministre qui a
passé une année entière sans nous donner
de direction que nous avons vu des
projets lois qui sont la plupart du
temps assez vides et qui consiste à
faire de la dérégulation nous assistons
finalement à quelque chose qui n'est
absolument pas constructif pour notre
République qui a besoin de réponses et
en plus nous voyons quand même
aujourd'hui un épanouissement des thèses
d'extrême droite dans la vie politique
qui paraît quand même assez étonnant en
termes d'apaisement alors
je crois que lorsque on pointe du doigt
non pas l'extrême droite mais
systématiquement l'ensemble de la route
en l'occurrence première ministre dedans
qu'elle était hors du champ République
ça veut dire que on ne peut pas faire ce
genre de choses parce que il y a une
différence que vous voyez sur ces images
et qui arrive justement à l'Assemblée
nationale pour cette dernière séance de
questions au Gouvernement elle revient
ici renforcée puisqu'elle a été
confirmée à son poste par le Président
de la République et par en tout cas
l'Elysée l'entourage de l'Elysée hier
soir merci à toutes les deux d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau pour cette
dernière séance on va tout de suite
retrouver Stéphanie despier on est dans
moins de 3 minutes de la séance de
questions au Gouvernement quelles sont
les principales questions de quoi on va
parler cet après-midi Stéphanie alors
Brigitte on va d'abord parler santé avec
l'été et la fermeture annoncée de
certains services d'urgence il y a des
inquiétudes un peu partout en France
notamment dans les zones tour et puis il
y a des inquiétudes aussi sur la
situation dans les EHPAD alors que les
thermomètres affichent des records
deuxième thème cet après-midi les prix
de l'électricité pardon ce sera plus 10%
au premier août soit 150 euros à peu
près par an parfois foyer alors il y a
beaucoup de questions sur cette
augmentation de tarifs et sur la fin
annoncée du bouclier tarifaire fin 2024
et puis dernier thème qui fait l'objet
de plusieurs questions la sécurité
routière et le permis de conduire après
les annonces de la première ministre
hier merci Stéphanie Despierre Elsa mon
incapa vous êtes salle des quatre
colonnes quelle est l'ambiance de votre
côté et bien écoutez là près de nous
c'est Olivier fort il était il y a
quelques instants au micro de Stéphanie
Despierres il leur répond aux questions
à des journalistes puisqu'il va
interroger le gouvernement sur le
remaniement le remaniement évidemment
tout le monde a ce mot là à la bouche
ici celle des quêtes colonnes alors qui
quel ministre seront concernés est-ce
que ce sera juste un ajustement
technique ou un remaniement d'ampleur un
peu plus politique la question c'est de
savoir quand alors on connaît à peu près
la borne un pas après dimanche puisque
le président de la République par en
tournée en Océanie du remaniement il se
rend pas forcément question lors de la
séance du gouvernement mais il est
évidemment dans toutes les têtes ici il
reste plus que quelques secondes avant
de rentrer dans l'hémicycle regardez la
présidente du groupe Aurore berger
Renaissance passe derrière nous pour la
dernière séance de question gouvernement
effectivement Elsa elle reste quelques
secondes moins d'une minute maintenant
avant l'arrivée de la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale nous sommes ici
Salle des pas perdue et je peux vous
dire qu'il y a déjà beaucoup de curieux
qui sont venus voir ce cérémonial que
l'on voit un présent chaque semaine
chaque mardi pour l'arrivée de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
peut-être Virgile va nous montrer avec
sa caméra le monde qui est venu
aujourd'hui pour cette dernière séance
de questions au Gouvernement vous voyez
il est possible d'assister de plus en
plus maintenant à ces séances en
s'inscrivant sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale et puis vous le voyez aussi
c'est la garderie républicaine qui est
là tout aligné et qui attend
effectivement
l'arrivée de Yaël Braun Pivet elle va
jouer du tambour dans quelques instants
puisque la présidence est annoncée dans
la salle des pas perdus d'ici quelques
secondes
[Musique]
et vous l'avez vu sur ces images la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
vient de traverser cette salle des pas
perdue et de franchir la salle des
séances elle est donc dans les mystique
de l'Assemblée nationale elle monte en
ce moment au perchoir pour présider
cette séance de questions au
gouvernement on va parler beaucoup de
santé avec la canicule dans les EHPAD
les prix de l'électricité très bonne
séance à tous on se retrouve juste après